It's great to welcome to the program today,
Megan Phelps Roper, who is author of the book
unfollow a journey from hatred to hope leaving
the Westboro Baptist church as the books title
implies. And Megan is a former member of the
Westboro Baptist church. I'm Megan. So great
to have you on. I'm glad we finally were able
to do this.
Finally, I feel like what we've been talking
by email since I was still a member of the
church, so this is the first time we've actually
spoken yet.
Yeah. Yeah. And for people, I mean, so people
may remember that years ago I interviewed,
um, some other folks from the Westboro Baptist
church, some who, uh, our biological relatives
of yours, some who are not and who, who maybe
we will, we will talk about. Um, but for people
who aren't familiar with you, I mean, what
a, your, your childhood in Kansas, what was
it like? What's your first sort of memory
of the Westboro Baptist church as what others
kind of know it to be?
I mean, I was, I was five years old when we
first started protesting a at a park, about
half a mile from, you know, my house, you
know, I lived on, uh, the block that, you
know, he shared with the church and several
other family members or was a, you know, you
know, fence and closing that whole area. So
for me, that space was a refuge. It was, you
know, it was filled with people that I loved
and who loved me. And then we would go out
to these protests. Like I said, it's starting
at this local park. And then branching out
from there, um, to be basically, you know,
everywhere outside of the church, anywhere
outside the church, um, was a legitimate target
for our protests. And so we would go out there
and, you know, the, that obviously there was
a lot of hatred on our signs. We would say
that it was the hatred of God, not our own
personal human hatred. Um, but the hatred
that was reflected back at us, um, was, was
ferocious. Um, you know, people driving their
cars at us, you know, throwing things. Um,
coming after us on foot. I mean, I, it was,
it was not an uncommon thing, um, for a long
time. So these are, these are my earliest
memories on the picket line
as far as you were concerned, the, the things
that you were protesting were, and I mean,
I guess the reason I asked that is the outward
facing side, if people are familiar with the
protest, they would say, well, these are homophobic
protests. These are protests that sometimes
are against the military. They're religiously
based protest. But like how did you conceive
of them from inside?
We saw it as loving our neighbor. We were
going to warn people of the consequences of
their sins. Um, which was an inherently loving
thing according to our understanding of the
Bible. Um, and you know, I was not an incurious
person. I was not, you know, as long as if
there was a, if we did anything, there had
to be a justification from the Bible. And
as long as there was, you know, I, I was trained
to believe that that was the infallible word
of God. And it was unquestionable. And I just,
I had to go along with it. Any, any thought
or feeling or doubt that I had was indicative
of a problem with me, not with the doctrine
or with Westboro itself.
Now, as you've talked about the fact that
you were doing this from such a young age
and maybe this became more of an issue, not
when you were five, but maybe more like eight,
nine, 10, you had to start dealing with the
reaction from people in the community, uh,
at least to some degree. Did you have, were
you sort of like prepared by others in the
church for that to happen? And what was the
kind of preparation that you were given or
the defense that you were given?
Yeah, we were absolutely prepared and it was
something that we, we talked about this every
single day. It looks like, you know, sitting
around our living room with, I'm the third
of 11 kids. So we would spend, you know, time
every evening reading the Bible, memorizing
Bible verses, you know, honestly being on
the picket itself was preparation, uh, on
the picket line itself because, you know,
they're, you're encountering people who obviously
strongly disagreed with our message and some
were willing to, you know, to articulate their
positions and arguments. And so we had to
be ready always, you know, and that's the
bylaws. Be ready always to give an answer
to every man that asks you a reason for the
hope that's in you with meekness and fear.
So it was something that we took deadly serious.
Um, and, and, and I did do, you know, we,
because we knew that the whole world was against
our message, we needed to be ready, um, with
Bible verses, you know, in hand memorized.
You can't, you know, pull out a Bible and
start looking things up. When you're standing
there and somebody is yelling in your face,
you have to be ready immediately to give them,
you know, to, to both to exhort and to confute
the gain Sayers, as my grandmas would say,
according to Bible, of course.
And when this happened and when people would
either challenge you on the substance of the
protests or sometimes of course it was, it
was not about the substance necessarily, but
it was you. You are all terrible people. You're
doing something that's horrible. You're hurting
other people. Did you, was, do you recall
that as being traumatic in some sense or had
you been so prepared for it and sort of equipped
for it that you did not feel it at least at
the time as a traumatic event?
I did not experience it as a traumatic event.
And in fact I remember one a moment early
on when we were going, we were going to a
protest that seemed like it was going to be
particularly acrimonious, acrimonious and
possibly even dangerous. And, and I was, I
was really small and I remember, and maybe
I was just being melodramatic, you know, I
was probably five or six and, and I kind of
whimpered a little bit and you know, I think
it was my mom. It was my mom who was like
basically cut that out. You know, the Lord
is with us. I experienced you when, when people
would accuse us of, of being hateful. Like
I knew that my intentions were not hateful.
I knew that I was trying to, to do the right
thing. So to do, you know, Gramps would say
that, you know, the world needs this message
more than they need food to eat, air to breathe
or water to drink. And no, again, I believe
that. And so when I just, I basically just
felt misunderstood. You know, these people
are making all these accusations, but that's
just because they don't understand God has
blinded them really where the good guys and,
and they, they just don't get it.
And you, at least at this point that we're
talking about right now, you were 110% behind
that as the interpretation of what was going
on at this point. There was not the doubt
that later started to surface.
Right? Absolutely. I was, I was all in
at this point. And when we talk about, when
I say your family, people may or may not know
your mom is Shirley Phelps Roper and then
Fred Phelps, your grandfather, um, were, was
your family, um, sort of loving and, uh, other
than this, which to the outside appears to
be a really horrible thing to expose a kid
to. But from the perspective from within the
church, it was, it was a loving thing to warn
people and to save people. Other than that,
what is your experience now having seen the
way other people were raised and live in the
world? Was it one of sort of like a loving
household in the traditional stereotypical
ways?
I would say there's, there's, there's two
parts to it, you know, there is absolutely,
it was full of love and care and, and you
know, I think of my parents, um, and you know,
the, I'm overwhelmed with those positive memories
and the time that we spent together. Um, and
yes, absolutely. You know, reading, I mean
other than the Bible, even reading together,
my dad would, you know, the way that my dad
did bedtime when I was a kid. I mean it's
just, it's just all these, you know, wonderful
memories. Um, but then of course, you know,
the, the, that hard line biblical stance that
we took toward outsiders that absolutely applied
to us inside as well. You know, we were held
to an extremely high particular, um, set of
standards and any deviation from that was
caused for, for punishment. And when I was
younger, that absolutely included physical
punishment.
Um, uh, and, and I would even say abuse. Um,
not, it wasn't every single time, but it absolutely
did, you know, frequently enough veer into
abuse. Um, at least in my family. And, and
I know that it was, you know, that what I
experienced was far less extreme even than
what my mom and her generation experienced.
Right. Um, so there, there was that side of
it and there was, you know, the, the absolute
terror that you feel, um, of, of going to
hell, um, of what God is going to do to you.
If you don't 100% toe the line on everything.
When I say everything I really mean everything.
It could come down to a look on your face
or a tone in your voice. Those kinds of things
could get you into deep trouble. And it's
one of those things that, you know, since
I left, you know, the relief that I feel at
not having this sort of constant attribution
of ill motives for you know, any possible,
you know, it just seemed like by the time
I left my sister and I, my sister grace left
with me. Um, by the time we left, you know,
the way we, the way we would describe it,
we would say everything that looks bad is
bad and everything that looks good is also
bad. It was just this, this there, there is
this wonderful sense of, I'm sorry I'm going
on here, but like there's an amazing sense
of community and togetherness, um, in, in
groups like Westboro. But there's also the
understanding, you know, the high, high cost
of, of deviation of any of any sort.
So you and grace eventually left. But let's,
let's build up to that where, well, first
of all, had, by the time you started experiencing
some doubts questions, I would love for you
to tell us when that was and what prompted
it. But were there other siblings or cousins
or whoever that had also already left at the
point? At that point?
Yes. So, uh, my brother Josh, he left when
I was 18 and he was 19. Um, so my, he was
the first person close to me who left the
church. I had heard about my siblings, of
my mothers, um, who had left and they were
just understood to be hell bound and hated
by God and, and just essentially disposable.
Like you understand that people who leave
are, they're disposable. You just, you just,
they're not our family anymore. You know,
there's a passage where Jesus says, who is
my mother and who has, who are my brother
and these that do the will of God. So the
people in the church, we're a family and everyone
outside of that was not right. So yes, I mean,
so there, there were others, there were cousins,
other, um, cousins who had left as well. And
so I had these examples, but they were not,
you don't take them as an example to follow
you take them, you take them as an example
of what you want to avoid. There's actually
almost the opposite effect. It's not something
like when somebody leaves that's close to
you, you don't feel like you want to follow
them. You feel like you want to, uh, you need
to prove yourself. It's almost like you throw
yourself even more deeply into the work of
the church to prove that you're not like them.
That's interesting. And is that, was there
an air, did you feel as though when someone
would leave that there would be an air of
suspicion that would be upon you and others?
Yep.
Yup. And, and not just suspicion, but just
worry, you know, and I needed to show people
that, you know, in fact, I, I went and looked
up, you know, when my cousin Libby left, I
had been, you know, pretty close to her and,
and I went and looked up, you know, the email
that I send, uh, afterwards to the whole church
basically, you know, feeling the need to say
bad things about her and to, to show that
I was not on the same page with her rebellion.
Um, so yeah, you asked a question though about,
well, so that's it. I mean, so that gets us
to what you had observed in terms of people
separating while you were still there. And
I mean, I guess I'd be, I want to hear a little
bit about what started the questions and the
doubts and the sort of looking into other
worldviews.
Right. So, uh, I got on Twitter in 2009 and
I didn't go on Twitter because I was looking
to have my mind changed. I got on Twitter
to spread Westborough his message.
And I think I remember when that happened.
In fact, and if correct me if I'm wrong, it
wasn't just you, but there were a couple of
your sisters who were maybe also doing the
same.
I was the only one tweeting publicly for a
while. I feel like it was maybe, maybe about
a year or something like that. Yeah. Um, and
then yes, absolutely. A bunch more people
got on. My mom got on, she was at dear Shirley.
Um, Margie. Um, yeah. And then I think some
of my uncles and, and others also. Um, so
yeah, but you know, when again, when I got
on, I wasn't trying to, I was just trying
to show other people while they were wrong,
why they were wrong and how, um, and but over
time, you know, several things happened, there
were a lot of things about Twitter that, that
were really powerful to me. First of all,
like the first thing, and this was the, I
think the one thing that I was conscious of
was that with only 140 characters, um, you
know, there wasn't space for the kind of insults
that we just, you know, threw around all the
time.
Like, yeah, I don't know if you remember that
era, but it was constant. Yeah. I mean, I
remember when Margie called me a Titmouse,
which might've had some, I mean, that one's
pretty short and pithy, but a lot of them
were much more involved than required. You
know, sort of being able to be, could be a
little bit more of a both. Yes. And so my
mom, every time, basically every time she
would like George W. Bush was the president
at the time, so she would say bombastic blow
hard, big mouth bastard. Uh, and so like there
just wasn't space for that on Twitter. And
then I realized that even when there, even
when there was space, even if when I did make
the space for it, you know, um, I would wash
the conversation immediately, just go off
the rails. Um, and we're no longer talking
about this theological point that I feel is
so important now.
It's this person being defensive because I've
called them a stupid name. Right. Um, and
so, you know, so I learned not to do that.
That was the first kind of step, I think,
uh, for me away. Um, but I mean that was just
a different, slightly different communication
style. I mean, I guess that opened the door
to at least interacting with people in a different
way. You still have your view, they still
have theirs. They're wrong. You're right.
But at least the method of communication has
shifted a little bit. Slightly. Exactly. Yeah.
But then, you know, so then one of the first
people that I attached when I got on Twitter
was this guy David Abitbol, who ran a blog
called Jewishness. And you know, I only attacked
him because, because he was Jewish because,
you know, Jews killed Jesus. Sure. As you
know, as I've been told many times.
Um, and so anyways, so he, um, he initially
responded like many other people just like
full of hostility and then, but pretty quickly
he recognized, he told, he said later he recognized
that I was sincere and that he thought it
was important to articulate, you know, why,
why have we as a society rejected messages
like West burrows for the people who were
following, both of us who would see both of
us. He thought it was important to offer a
counterpoint. So he wasn't even necessarily
at first trying to reach me specifically.
Um, and so, but you know, again, so over time
of, over about a year, we're having these
conversations where he's asking me questions
about our picket signs and I'm asking him
questions about Judaism and Jewish theology.
And the only reason I'm asking is I want to
find better ways of countering his points.
Um, but he was the first person, you know,
after that, you know, about a year of conversation
who found the first internal inconsistency
in Westboro is doctrine.
And for me, like that was absolutely the moment
that was the beginning of the end inconsistency.
It was actually one I realized this morning
cause I went back and looking at, there was
a couple of videos, interviews that you had
done that I wanted to like what am I remembering
this correctly? Um, so I went and looked up
a couple of them and you, you, you mentioned
it, you mentioned the, um, death penalty for,
you know, the sign calling for the death penalty
for gays and you know, it that was the, you
know, a point that David made, you know, I'm
saying what, you know, my uncle said to you,
if that punishment is good enough for God,
then it's good enough for us. That's what
the mosaic code calls for. And so therefore,
you know that that's it. That's, that's the
standard. And David said, well, didn't Jesus
saying what he who is without sin cast the
first stone?
Um, you didn't mention that. You mentioned
the other point that David made, which was,
um, you mentioned my mom, you know, had my
oldest brother out of wedlock and we had answers
to both of those arguments. When somebody
would say, you know what, he was without sin,
cast the first stone. We would say, we're
not casting stones, we're preaching words.
And David again points out the obvious response
to that, which is yeah, but you're advocating
that the government cast stones and you know
who, who were there is sinless. Um, and then
also, you know, the, the point about my mother,
like we would always say, you know, she repented
of that sentence, so therefore she doesn't
deserve that punishment. But of course, again,
if you kill somebody as soon as they sin,
then they don't have the opportunity to repent
and be forgiven if you just, you know.
And so I realized, of course, if my mother
had been killed, my, my family wouldn't exist.
The hypocrisy of it was so apparent to me.
Um, and so yeah, it just was a, I didn't know
what to make of it. You know, I decided to
stop holding that sign. I went to my mother
and a couple of the older people in the church
and asked about this and was just told that,
um, you know, I was getting wrapped around
an axle and the point is they're not going
to Institute the death penalty. And, and I
just really like, you know, if we were making
this a litmus test, why, why is that? You
know, why isn't the, the fact that they're
not doing it like the actually, you know,
doing what Jesus said, not having, you know,
trying to kill people for their sins, giving
them the opportunity to repent and be forgiven.
So that for me that, that was the first time
I realized that we could be wrong. You know,
I believed before that all my life there had
always been an answer, you know, something,
something from the Bible that would explain
our position. And so yeah, this was mind blowing
for me.
So what, how long did that, so that was maybe
the catalyst and then it continued. How long
did the process take while you were still
in the church but increasingly questioning.
Okay. So it was, that was I think November
of 2010 that conversation with David, it was
July of 2012 when I finally, finally had this
realization that like, Oh my God, what if
we're just people? What if this isn't the
place led by God himself? And, and then it
was another four months after that before
I actually, the day I actually walked out
the door, like I had, you know, in that time,
that four month period, I kind of was going
back and forth between thinking, you know,
am I, am I crazy? Like I kind of thought,
you know, this was Satan whispering in my
ear. It was, it was, it was a test from God
that I was failing. Um, and, but then also,
you know, understanding like, you know, going
through all of these questions and doubts
in my mind and realizing like, no, this is
absolutely wrong. This cannot be right. And
so
I, uh, I've interviewed a lot of former Scientologists
and when they describe leaving, they talk
about there are physical impediments to doing
that. Sometimes it involves escaping, sometimes
it involves all sorts of physical stuff. In
your case it was different. I mean it was
a different, leaving means something different
in your case.
Yep, absolutely. I mean there is no, they
would say this is a volunteer army, right?
This isn't, we're not, we don't want anybody
here who doesn't want to be here. So if you
don't want to be here and he just need to
leave, you know, my, my parents helped me
pack. It was not for Westboro. You know, there
are, there are definitely aspects of Westboro
that are Colt. Like this is one where it's
not, you know, they're, they're not trying
to force anyone's hand. If, you know, physically
speaking, they will use all kinds of, you
know, threats of eternal torment. And you
know, obviously the, the shunning process,
which is common to basically every cult that
has ever existed. Um, but they're not trying
to physically stop people from leaving.
And when you say that this is what you're
doing, what's the conversation? Is it, we're
not going to be in touch anymore? Is it, I
mean, how does that sort of go?
You just, you just understand, you know that
when people leave, you know that there, that
there is no contact there. You know, I would
occasionally, when I was a member of the church,
like somebody would ask me, well like what
if you saw so-and-so X member out in the grocery
store or whatever? Like what would you say
to them? And I just could draw nothing but
a blank. Like what? Everything has been said.
There's nothing left to say this person has
held down, they've rejected God and that's
all there is to it. There is never any sense
at Westboro that there is a, there's no legitimate
reason to leave ever there. Or even even if
we, if and when they come to recognize that
they were wrong about something, they will
never acknowledge that as a reason to leave.
Although they will look at every other church
and say, well, you saw the X, Y,Z was wrong.
Like why didn't you leave immediately? You
knew that that couldn't be a godly place because
they were, they had the central doctrine but
they never recognize that in themselves. And
so X members are just again, totally disposable.
So you left, as you mentioned earlier with
one of your sisters. Was that, I mean, what,
how much planning and conversation with her
sort of goes into it?
That was absolutely terrifying. You know,
cause Nope, as far as I know, no one has ever,
everybody is always left alone. You know,
you understand that, you know, you can't trust
anybody, you know, you can't, you know, they,
they are supposed to, you know, according
to this passage in Deuteronomy, you know,
if you go to somebody and say, let us go and
serve other gods, right. This, this, I don't,
I don't think this is right. Um, they're the
ones who are supposed to turn you in, um,
for stoning of course, again, you know, West
not going to be actually starting people,
but, but that, you know, the implication there,
the understanding that if you go and talk
to somebody about any of these things, um,
that they're supposed to turn you in, um,
and not, they're not supposed to hide you.
Um, and so anyway, so for me to go to my sister,
you know, I felt like I had to because I had
been talking with her about some of these
doubts and never to the extent of actually
doubting Westboro itself.
But, you know, we talked about it and she
was the only person who, you know, gave any
quarter to the idea that, that we could be
wrong about anything. Um, and I just, I felt
like I had to talked to her before, before
leaving. And so it was, like I said, it was
the, those four months we were kind of going
back and forth. You know, I wanted to talk
about all the things that I knew were wrong.
I had come to believe are wrong. I wasn't,
I knew that I was not gonna protest anymore
funerals. I was not going to pray for any
more people to die over, bad things to happen
to others. Um, I knew I wasn't going to hold
certain signs that I then believed were unscriptural.
Um, but I wanted to focus on those things
and my sister wanted to focus on what it was
going to cost us, what it was going to mean
to leave.
And so in that time you asked about preparation,
you know, we were doing all of these things.
So, you know, taking photos and voice recordings
and collecting family recipes and copying
dozens of DVDs worth of home movies and you
know, all these things that we would forever
lose access to once we left. You know, asking
my parents about how they met and this whole,
you know, just all these questions that you
would never, I just never thought really to,
to really dig into. And so we were doing all
of those things and, but part of it was absolutely
a stalling tactic. You know, maybe during
this time we, you know, we're asking questions
and trying to, you know, very gently change
people's minds from the inside and just being
met over and over again. It was like hitting
a brick wall again and again, nothing was
changing. Um, but we kept hoping that it would.
And the first, I don't know, couple of weeks,
couple of months after you left, I mean, what
was your time mostly sort of consumed by
the first month? My sister was still in school,
so we moved, uh, to Lawrence, Kansas to live
with another X number, one of my cousins.
Um, and my sister was commuting four days
a week to, to Pico. It was half an hour away
for her classes. So it was just this, I think,
full of just logistical, like how do you live
outside of Westboro. Um, and also a lot of,
a lot of fear. There was, I mean, I basically
w I kinda at that point still believed in
hell. I still believed that God was gonna,
you know, maybe strike me down on getting
some awful car accident. Um, or you know,
some other kind of, you know, you know, my
mom would say that the weapons in God's arsenal
are innumerable. Um, and I, I believe that.
So I would have these like visions of these
terrible things happening to me for a long
time after I left, I would say, I mean, probably
for the first year.
Um, and, and then after that first month,
my sister and I decided to run away to South
Dakota and read books. We went to Deadwood,
South Dakota. Um, we basically at that point
were, were just w we realized we were still
running into our family all the time in Topeka.
And you're driving by protests at the grocery
store, just everywhere. Um, and so we realized
we needed to get away. So we drove 12 hours
to Deadwood, South Dakota and brought a bunch
of books because we were trying to basically
build a worldview from scratch. Like, what
if Westboro isn't true? If the Bible isn't
everything, you know, then you've got a lot
of catching up to do, so to speak. Absolutely.
Absolutely. So, so, and there was, there was
so much, you know, in that, you know, I, I've
talked about this moment, uh, you know, being
in the public library in Lawrence, Kansas
and just looking up at these stacks of philosophy
books and just wave of kind of humiliation
and shame washing over me.
And like, how had we ever believed that we
alone had, had the truth and everyone else
was wrong and to believe that so confidently
and to have no question about it. You know,
grams would say that, you know, about how
there's something liberating about being 100%
right. There was never any question in our
minds and how, how could we have thought that?
Um, anyway, so there's, it was, but, but very
shortly, like while I was in Deadwood, um,
it was about less than two months after I
left, I saw this hash like I had largely at
that point, I had been super active on Twitter
and I had stopped after that moment in July
of 2012. And, uh, this, this hashtag appeared,
you know, is Megan Phelps Roper. And you know,
these people, like, you know, people who hated
Westboro, who hated my family, you're taunting
them on Twitter, you know, saying, you know,
sending to people into Pico, like to the picket
line and to drive by my house to see it.
My car was there. And you know, it felt like,
to me it felt like being hunted and like I
had to, you know, face this past that. I still
didn't understand that. I was trying to figure
out, like, I had come to believe that we were
wrong, but I didn't understand, you know,
what was right or what, what I was supposed
to do about any of it. And, you know, it was,
it was terrifying. So I, I, you know, three
months after I left, I put up this statement
basically, um, and did one interview and then,
you know, basically saying I did everything
that I did because I thought it was right.
Um, I thought I had to, I thought it wasn't,
you know, I thought this was the most important
thing in the world. Um, I've come to believe
that that's wrong and here are some reasons
why.
And I hope that what I do from no on and the
way that I live from no one, um, the changes
that I make in my life will, will speak for
themselves. So it's been seven years now since
you left, is that right? Yeah. In that time,
what degree of contact, if any, have you had
with people that are still part of the church?
Almost none. I mean I sent, I reach out to
them regularly. Um, just to be clear, like
I know that I was changed by um, outsiders,
the kindness and compassion and gentle persuasion
of outsiders. And I know that, you know, I
have a friend who basically said, you know,
they have demonized you more than, you know,
X members. They demonize X members more than
anyone else. The likelihood that you are going
to be the voice that gets through to them
is extremely small.
And, and I think she was trying, and I'm,
I'm glad she said it. It was one of those
things that, you know, I immediately felt
immense resistance to, you know, cause I,
I realized I didn't want to, I didn't want
to not reach out to them. I didn't want to
not try to fail to try. Seemed like, like
giving up, you know. And I, I didn't, I didn't,
I didn't, I didn't want to do that. I w I
still love them dearly. I think that they
are deeply misguided and have heard a lot
of people and you know, taught me to do the
same thing. And I, I obviously, obviously
that's wrong. And, um, but I don't think that
isolating them or just going on with my own
life, that changes nothing for them. And,
and so, so I have, I started reaching out
to them.
My sister and I both did. Um, and you know,
initially probably just, you know, to tell
them that we loved them. And, but then again,
almost immediately though it was, it became
about trying to make arguments that they could
here to change their minds, to help them moderate
their positions in some way. And so that has
been, and I occasionally get responses in
largely it's on Twitter, you know, recently,
um, you know, one of the things that I have
talked about is, is how unscriptural our funeral
protests were, you know, and things like,
you know, the apostle Paul saying to the weak,
I became as weak that I might gain the week.
That's not what we did. We went to the week
and we, we danced on the American flag, we
played flag soccer, we sang happy birthday
September 11. As these mourners are walking
by sometimes just a few yards away. Like that
was not to the week I became this week. That
is not speaking the truth in love. Um, and,
and many other passages. And I actually got
my, my uncle recently on Twitter just to acknowledge
that that kind of spiteful joy, he says spiteful
joy is never wrong. Like he won't actually
acknowledge that that's what they were doing.
He won't say they, they will actually apologize.
They will not repair those breaches that they
made and to, to, but I again, that's another
thing that I hope to convince them to do eventually.
So, I mean, as far as the, of course you've
said that the specific beliefs that were being
espoused through the protests, you, you don't
believe you've distanced yourself from, what
are your religious views now? Like, do you
still consider yourself a Protestant Christian
to some degree?
No, not at all. I am not religious at all
anymore. I mean, I still, I still read the
Bible. Um, but it's not, it's not because
I believe that it has all of the answers to
every question that might, you know, be in
the universe, but just because one, I mean
it's, it's everywhere. You know, it's, the
Bible is quoted in all kinds of literature.
Like I, I think that there are a lot of wonderful
things in the Bible. There's also a lot of
really terrible things in the Bible. And I
now no longer, I don't accept the good. I
mean, except the bad because of the good or
reject the good because of the bad. And like
my Ted talk a couple of years ago, the thrust
of that talk was essentially love your enemies.
Um, so obviously from Jesus
as far as, I mean, I'm curious about your
perception. You know, I've, I've stopped interviewing
the people from the church several years ago.
People have asked me why and I said, well,
listen, every, everything is a balance of,
um, is if it's a bad idea, is it prominent
enough that it's worth fighting and otherwise
we may just be better off not paying attention
to it. My perception is that the amount of
attention that the church gets, that its prominence
has been significantly diminished since the
time that you left. And so I've made the call
that I don't think there's really much to
gain by doing the interviews, but is my, is
your sense that my perception is correct that
the church is significantly diminished from
where it was a decade ago?
Absolutely. Yeah. No, I don't think there's
any question about that. I think part of it
is a result of the fact that they have moderated
in some ways. It's also partly because, you
know, the like I'm in a lot of their new signs
or things like, you know, racism is a sin
or be reconciled to God. So any sign that
in any hand that's the holding those signs
is not holding, you know, God hates fags or
something. Um, and not that those signs are
all gone, but a lot of them are like, I mean,
they, that, that's one of the things I mentioned.
The, uh, pray for more dead soldiers, pray
for more dead kids. Those signs aren't, aren't
out there anymore either. So a lot of the
things that they were doing that got them
so much attention, um, they're either not
doing or, or, but also I feel like there's
somebody else pointed out, there's just so
much hatred in the world right now. The, the
polarization and the, you know, inability
to converse across ideological lines like
has just massively increased the amount of,
of hatred. And so novelty,
it's depressing in the sense that there's
been so much coarsening of the political discourse
that, I mean, of course the messages are still
absolutely horrible from the Westboro Baptist
church to the extent that they're the same
messages from before. But the fact that it's
less unique as course in political discourse
is in a sense, extremely disturbing.
It is. It really is. And that's, you know,
somebody, I saw somebody call it the West
rotation of politics. And I think that's true.
So as you know, Westboro itself has actually
kind of gotten lost in the middle of that.
Um, you know, again, which again, it's, it's
really sad. I think, you know, I, I've been
doing, you know, whatever I can to encourage
people to, to not give into those impulses,
to, you know, try to shame people and shame
is a really powerful tool. I, I want to be
clear, like I understand shame is a powerful
tool and then it does work in certain situations,
right? So, um, I've been talking lately about,
I was talking to an anthropologist last year
who defined shame as the feeling we get when
we have violated the norms of our community.
And you know, that's, that's the key.
That last part, the norms of our community
when we have, we have the tribalism in this
country right now. We are so divided that
we, we see the shaming of people on the other
side. Like we take that as a badge of honor
just like we did at Westborough. It was something
that, you know, it was, it was proof of our
righteousness. If these evil people think
that we're wrong and, and you know, like that,
that's something that shows that we're right.
And so it wasn't shame that changed me. It
was again, the compassion and empathy of people
who took the time to try to understand where
I was coming from, who made me feel heard.
Um, and, and who were able to, you know, find
these internal and consistencies and, you
know, build rapport over time.
Yeah. My audience will probably be almost
sick of me saying this at this point, but
whenever I talk to someone that left any kind
of hate group or extremist groups, sometimes
they're called, sometimes they're not. The
number one thing that they cite as what could
have number one prevented them from getting
sucked in in the first place. For people who
were recruited, not for people who were born
into something or what was most responsible
for getting them out was people outside of
their ideology being empathetic. And it might
come with facts in some cases, but what's
clear is that just beating people over the
head with the facts alone seems very ineffective
at changing lines.
Yeah, no, absolutely. And that was one of
the things like, we haven't talked about this
yet, but uh, I think I did mention this to
you once. Your show is actually inadvertently
responsible or indirectly responsible for
my marriage.
Yeah. I wonder if you go to that next and
it's good that you eat. We emailed about this
a couple of years ago and I've fortunately,
I don't remember the details, so there'll
be sort of new to me as you tell them now.
What is that connection?
Um, so when you had my mom on the show in
I think it was February of 2011, I'm sure
it was, I was February, 2011 and, and, uh,
anonymous Jake Davis who has been known as
topiary, right then you had him on and they
took over West bros website. And, uh, that
became, it was, it was a huge, I mean, I don't
know how much, uh, yeah, I can't tell exactly
how many views you got on that.
I think it's gotta be six or 7 million at
this point.
Yeah. Was insane. And it
happens so fast. And, um, so that became this
international news story and it ended up in
the RSS feed of this, uh, man in Eastern South
Dakota who, um, sent me a message on Twitter
that was initially, you know, again, kind
of, he, he said nasty or crude. Um, I responded,
you know, flippantly, kind of the way I always
did it. Um, and, and that started a conversation.
Like he, he was impressed with my grammar
and super nerdy. Um,
but yeah, this, and so he was anonymous for
the first, like seven months. We were talking,
um, this is actually all this is all part
of the book, but, um, you know, we start playing
words with friends. He's asking all these
questions about the church. He's a lawyer,
you know, like my family. So he had, you know,
it was right around the time we won that U
S Supreme court case, Snyder V Phelps. And
so, yeah, just started these conversations
and he was one of those voices. Um, his arguments
were not the, you know, logical, theological,
um, they were more about their emotional arguments,
you know, I would be talking about, um, and,
and for him feed the funeral protests and
celebrations of death and tragedy. He just
could not get past you. Like you're coding
all these things in the Bible. And I'm looking
them up. I see that they're there, but I cannot
imagine going to these families and telling
them, you know, while they're burying their
child to pray for more dead kids.
I don't, I don't understand. I don't understand
how that's how that's biblical or how, that's
right. Um, so anyway, that and then, you know,
eventually, you know, after seven months I
had this dream about, you know, meeting him
and in the dream I embrace him and I wake
up from that dream realizing like, Oh my God,
I can never talk to this person again. So
I, you know, cut off communication with him
and then I left. I ended up leaving. It was
a year later, about a year later. Um, anyways,
when I met him and he was just as great in
person
and now we have a daughter, she just turned
one. Yeah. That is compressing an incredible
story in the last, and we met and worked together
and now we have, we have a daughter that,
that's an incredible story. Well, to the extent
that I played a positive role in it, uh, I,
that's a good thing. I mean, what uh, what
else could it accidentally I guess we would
say. Yeah, absolutely. It was really cool
cause I met topiary. J Davis, he eventually
was like arrested and charged in the UK. Um,
he was something unrelated to hacking the
Westport
it have to do with Westborough has U S other,
other activities of his and uh, but yeah,
it's like, it's so cool meeting these people
who had this, you know, obviously again, I
know you didn't, you didn't mean for it to
happen, but
no, I am so grateful your show exists. Thank
you. What was it? I really appreciate your
time. I want to tell everybody to get the
book on, follow a journey from hatred to hope.
Megan was kind enough to send me a PDF a couple
of weeks ago and I got through as much of
it as I could before the interview and I,
I will absolutely be finishing it. Uh, we've
been speaking with Megan Phelps, Roper. Megan,
I really appreciate your, and it's so great
that we were
finally able to do this. Yeah. Thank you so
much for having me.